the Florida Board of Education votes to
expand the so-called don't say gay rules
through 12th grade as you guys know it's
not called don't say gay I think it's
hb1557 if I'm not mistaken uh originally
it was going to be up to third grade it
is not that they are never going to
allow you to say anything about gay
people the word gay is not even in the
thing it's that you will learn about
certain things related to gender and sex
inappropriate classes like Health not in
math or science Etc but Ted Liu Senator
congressman Ted Lou I I cannot stand
this guy like he's to me at like Schiff
he's at like Schiff
um who else would I put in that small
well territory here's what he said about
it
kids in Maga States will be kept
ignorant they won't know gay marriage is
the law they won't be taught facts that
make them uncomfortable they will be
cuddled in a Maga bubble and when they
go to work or trade school or college
they will be made fun of and
disrespected he's a total I'm sorry he
is just such a dishonest scumbag I have
gone after well here's what I tweeted at
him just we'll just put it out there hey
Ted would you like to do my show so I
can call you a lying to your face
so you know sometimes I go with sugar
and sometimes I don't
Sarah again Gay's not in the thing
um I just I'll I'll ask you a personal
question when you were growing up at any
point from kindergarten to 12th grade
did you know the sexuality of your
teacher their their sexual habits where
they sit were they pulling you aside and
calling you Sam instead of Sarah would
any of that have been remotely
appropriate or am I just am I just an
old angry guy at this point no I
actually did not know any of those
personal details about my teacher's sex
life and I think if I did the teachers
would have been pulled aside very
quickly and removed from their duties as
a teacher because anyone who was alive
up until about like two years ago knows
that that's not appropriate for children
the don't say gay thing pisses me off at
probably as well maybe as much as it
pisses you off I mean you're in Florida
I'm not in Florida but to see it
characterizes this so disingenuously you
might as well call it the don't say
straight bill I guess right because
clearly that's not what it is but you
know you look at how the left co-ops
this language in order to try to push
their agenda you see them do it with
black lives matter was that organization
at all about saving black lives I mean
there was one black life they saved in
particular who now lives in a giant
mansion that she bought with all of the
black lives matter money that they
raised yeah but other than that nothing
right you have antifa are they actually
anti-fascist I don't think so because
anytime I run into them they're
literally trying to shut my speech down
which is kind of fascist of them so they
just take these phrases and they
manipulate them to use whatever they
want to do to demonize us as if at the
end of the day any reasonable adult
wants children learning about sex in
class it just it's so disingenuous and
at the end of the day they have to do
this they have to talk about it's don't
say gay they have to frame it this way
because they know that any reasonable
American uh you see my cat up here hello
early
um any reasonable American who looks at
the actual content of the bill will say
yeah we don't want people we don't want
our children learning about sex it's
very simple that's why they have to
frame it like this because they know
they're not winning on the issues and by
the way Ted Lu 100 is lying and he knows
he's lying when he says they will not
learn about gay marriage it's not we
actually teach Civics in Florida they've
passed a bill so it will actually have
to be taught an honest assessment of
History will have to be taught so
they're not going to ignore Supreme
Court decisions it's about sexualizing
children with teachers if you'd like
more sane takes on our insane World
check out our direct message clips
playlist and if you want to watch more
full episodes of our live roundtables
watch our round tables playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell